как забить на мнение окружающих когда
вас критикуют когда высказывают в
отношении Вас негатив или высказывают
какой-то хейт Стоит ли это делать
Давайте поговорим сегодня об этом В этом
видео я вам расскажу о правильном
отношении к критике хейт негативу и так
далее и более того я вам а расскажу
лайфхаки как извлекать из этого пользу а
в тех случаях когда извлечь пользу
невозможно Как научиться игнорировать
такое негативное мнение критику или хейт
полностью забивать на мнение окружающих
конечно же не надо потому что мы должны
чётко понимать что это обратная связь от
реальности и она является мощным
источником развития и улучшения нас
поэтому во всём этом потоке негатива
хейта критики недоброжелательность мы
должны уметь чётко отделять полезное от
не полезного я вас сегодня научу
пользоваться этим мощным каналом
обратной связи для своего же блага я вам
дам сегодня три основных принципа или
правил правильного отношения к мнению
окружающих первое поделите все мнения
окружающих или Весь хейт или комментарий
негативные которые у вас пишут под видео
или где бы то ни было под вашим постом
поделите на полезные и вредные
независимо от их тона К сожалению мы
когда читаем такие комментарии мы
ориентируемся прежде всего на тон а
ориентироваться надо на полезность или
вредность или ещё по-другому говорят на
конструктивную критику и не
конструктивную Что подразумевается под
этими терминами конструктивная - это
подразумевается что из неё можно извлечь
какую-то пользу и улучшить своё
поведение не конструктивная критика -
это когда просто Хаят Хаят и ругают вас
поэтому любые мнения под вашим постом
неважно под вашим интервью или где бы то
ни было Даже если вам говорят ваши
коллеги в офисе просто поделите на
полезные и вредные при этом постарайтесь
не обращать внимание на сам тон полезную
обратную связь там критику хейт полезный
э либо комментарии Выпишите в отдельный
список для дальнейшего внедрения и
улучшения в своей жизни или я часто ещё
такой негативный отзыв пишу у себя в
список к размышлению бывают такие вещи
которые я понимаю что Та сторона
возможно права и возможно я не прав но
мне надо над этим поразмыслить Как мне
изменить своё поведение и поэтому я в
блокноте У меня есть список называется к
размышлению Я записываю туда поэтому
научитесь не обращать внимание на тон
отделить по принципу полезное не
полезное а полезное выписывайте в
отдельный список над которым дальше надо
будет работать неполезные пока отложите
в сторону и я вам расскажу как работать
с ними тот список Когда вы взяли весь
этот негатив хейт комментарии и так
далее выбрали оттуда полезное выписали в
этот список вы берёте всё остальное и
просто игнорируете и тут возникает
вопрос Ага легко сказать игнорируете а
как это сделать и вот тут я вам дам ещё
новые три лайфхака Теперь Как
игнорировать мнение окружающих и именно
это тот случай про который я в начале
говорил в начале нашего видео как забить
на мнение этих окружающих первое вы вы
должны понять одну важную вещь что у
всех полно своих проблем вот взгляните
на себя просто Проанализируйте свой день
сколько времени в течение дня вы
посвящается тому чтобы думать о других
людях Или об их проблемах вот сколько
времени вот реально Посмотрите правде в
глаза ведь на самом деле в течение дня
вы особо и не думаете о других людях в
течение дня у вас своих проблем хватает
что у вас Мало проблем над которыми надо
думать что у вас Мало проблем которыми
надо заниматься Да нету такого вы просто
когда смотрите какого-то блогера
Например если например вы сами написали
какой-то хейт вы просто посмотрели сразу
у вас какая-то появилась реакция вы
сразу написали это в комментарии и
забыли Вы должны чётко понимать
что у всех людей полно своих проблем и
им точно не до вас поэтому не
переживайте Это первый способ Как
игнорировать чужое негативное мнение
второй способ имейте в виду те люди
которые осуждают вас они больше и
зачастую осуждают себя и их комментарии
даже если они написали вам какие-то злые
комментарии они больше направлены на
самих себя то есть они как бы смотрят
как в зеркало они как бы видят себя и
свои недостатки в зеркале и высказывают
свою ненависть и негодование именно к
тем качествам которые есть у них самих
поэтому не воспринимайте всё на свой
счёт Например если во мне есть условно
ненависть нелюб Нелюбовь негатив к лений
то когда я вижу проявление лений Я
обязательно напишу комментарии и скажу
Вот ты ленивая там какая-нибудь обидное
слово напишу но это не значит я имею в
виду этого человека Я имею в виду что я
ненавижу лень которая проявляется в нём
но ненавижу то я свою лень и поэтому
этот негатив больше направлен на лень
нежели на этого человека поэтому имейте
в виду что когда люди осуждают вас то
зачастую они осуждают не вас а те
Качества которые они в вас увидели как в
зеркале и которые не нравятся им самим
третье третье всегда помните Что
обсуждают и осуждают всегда те люди
которые находятся ниже вас потому что те
люди которые круче вас которые успешны
вас им точно не до вас смотрите такую
вещь те люди к мнению которых стоило бы
прислушиваться те люди мнение которых
стоило бы ценить Им просто не до вас они
не будут хейт писать вам Поэтому всегда
держите в голове что все кто пишет Вам
хейт негодование критику и так далее это
как правило люди ниже вас а те Кто круче
вас Им не до вас в таком случае стоит ли
прислушиваться к мнению людей и
переживать по поводу мнения тех людей
мнение которых вы не Цените и которые
ниже вас когда мне задают вопрос А как
же относиться к мнению близких людей
друзей родственников и так далее когда
они высказывают это мнение негативное Но
эти правила которые я здесь сказал они
применимы тоже то есть очень часто
бывает так что у человека плохой день и
и у него плохое настроение свои проблемы
и он просто это изливает на других
поэтому Когда вам говорят что-то
негативное первое Посмотрите реально
есть ли в этом польза Действительно ли
она конструктивная если если есть в этом
польза то постарайтесь не обращать
внимание на тон а поблагодарить этого
человека Когда вы поблагодарите этого
человека и покажете что вы приняли Этот
человек не будет настаивать дальше
второй момент Бывает такая ситуация что
человек негативно что-то говорит и вы не
можете понять это вы это полезно или не
полезно в таком
случае хороший лайфхак Задайте прямо
вопрос ему что ты предлагаешь мне
сделать или что ты хочешь чтобы я сделал
очень часто бывает так что если человек
а высказывает не конструктивную критику
то он не может предложить план что он на
самом деле сам не может сформулировать
что он хочет от тебя у него просто идёт
злость или просто негатив тогда вам
легче игнорирует и вы понимаете что это
значит чит либо у него там свои проблемы
настроение плохое и так далее просто
отстрани и так далее А если он тебе
конкретно говорит что делать или что он
хотел бы чтобы ты сделал тогда уже вы
можете задавать уточняющие вопросы и
извлекать пользу из негативной обратной
связи и очень важно помнить такую вещь
что для того чтобы решить любую проблему
очень важно соблюдать два правила первое
глядеть на проблему второе отводить
взгляд очень часто Когда незнакомый
человек высказывает какой-то негатив
достаточно просто взглянуть ему в глаза
Показать что вы поняли или даже просто
прямо спросить его А что ты хочешь от
меня или что ты хочешь и этого вполне
достаточно чтобы остановить его агрессию
А вообще в целом если вам интересна эта
тема и вы хотите больше узнать об этом
переходите на мой Telegram канал ссылку
я оставляю Внизу там мы можем говорить и
рассуждать об этом более подробно
поэтому не переживайте я вам дал три
способа Как относиться к негативному
мнению окружающих и Как игнорировать их
Поэтому двигайтесь вперёд собаки лают
караван идёт Желаю вам удачи